why were you making a strong big lady
gets here oh so close just a sliver left
oh man even stuff about if I don't
interrupt the match so I'm going to
frustrate myself let's all just watch
see how this big oily beast handles for
you ACK on your weird dude but I kind of
like it
Oh
on the ropes he's gotten with the corner
he's got it in the bear hunt and that's
it we have our first dev demolish of the
night one more all right hop it hop in
wait what's your name hi again all right
go for it again rematch putting up a bit
more of a fight chipping away at that
big oily man there it is okay okay
coming down to it here
as both players oh no so close ah big
belly flop oh that's almost it there
it's gonna go down we got our hype wolf
on the scene ladies and gentlemen your
first involvement Combofiend well fought
you've been demolished I did I have I
see like all the balance changes that I
made to this character were used against
me so congratulations well it's pretty
much best card game ever made well what
talk specifically about the ECC what's
up what's up with that card blizzcon
2013 exclusive card and you'll see the
animation when he uses it right up here
oh my
can we put this massive murloc
extravaganza up on screen or does Andy
have to sneak in here and point out
there we go look at all those how many
of you would consider getting a tattoo
of a murloc that is a little bit more
than I thought actually yeah nice I'll
pay for it and you'll get it all right
we're going to be crowdfunding a murloc
tattoo for this guy over here see some
some shake and bake happening putting
some damage on that harbor ooh all right
Oh Michael how you doing buddy well I'm
pretty nervous like yes it he's catching
up and I know unless I get really really
lucky we're gonna see how Michael fares
against Eric here and then we're going
to do the titanfall collector's edition
giveaway so y'all start reviewing
titanfall action in your mind
oh man Eric pulls it out in a very good
match hey you guys enough DLC today we
did we've got a upcoming map pack
expansion and the cool thing is that
we're also doing a bunch of free updates
and that included some really awesome
stuff that we were talking about one
that I think everybody here will really
like because this is a really
community-focused show and that is
hashtag matchmaking which slothy over
there on the end will be the the best
voice for but basically you can set a
hashtag and you can so if you wanted to
have one where you're gonna play with
people who love you know your podcast
your company whatever you can just say
like hashtag respawn and you'll play
with respawn piece but the other people
like respond so help match you at people
that like you know you might actually
like unlike the rest of everybody on
xbox live that sounds really cool
hashtag for PC hashtag not terrible
individuals that's who I like to play
with alright slothy i'll talk to you
about that in a second this so far is is
this broad whether more even matches you
played tonight yeah this one's really
good this is a good match he's they've
obviously played I see a lot of intense
faces over there you're rocking the car
SMG this is one of my favorites I do you
like the did the distance on this thing
it's not that not super great a distance
the lot of people play the carbine you
just got vested by it but how do you how
do you feel about how the car stacks up
I like both I mean it's actually use
both pretty interchangeably and the
challenges make it interesting to try
both I'm not strongly opinionated on
that one
I can roll with either one right on all
right we'll let you continue to wait
attrition war here just about up by just
about ten points it looks like you're
down a man though as justin is just
sitting here literally scrolling through
like four mini office looks pretty good
whoever's the count this is logged on
elsewhere and kicked me out of the game
oh no and that's Sean saves Tokyo so
that's gamespot editor Sean McGinnis so
you probably got logged out for like
Hulu Plus that his wife is watching the
magic of live entertainment ladies and
gentlemen we've been ignoring the
elephant in the room what is this what
is this situation you have going on here
who you dressed as all right you've got
a speaker for you here we go give us it
give us the right here step to the side
here give us a rundown Nintendo wolfman
Nintendo wolfman yup we got some wheat
accoutrements got glowing source Wii
Sports look at that shirt check it out
and we got sound effects but on the
sound effects done oh you know sound
effects right now alright I feel weird
about this I often that's a first for me
biking your butt that's cool ah awesome
thank you for coming in full regalia
it's probably not gonna over again
alright we're doing that yes yeah like
what wolf pound oh one of the more
challenging matches as Nintendo wolf
goes through the selection process here
mix kami let's see some let's see some
trash talking emotes here yeah Oh
Combofiend how do you feel about this
kind of intimidation coming your way I
mean this is you know certainly an
unorthodox opponent
I don't even think I could concentrate
on the match I just want to look at him
it's Ahmet it's the mental game and
you're already losing it
did you guys see that shot it's hard to
tell what's on the underside of those
paws oh no you know these fight sticks
were great and all four tournament
double play but mad catz really doesn't
consider the cosplay demographic
oh yeah whoopee going to town
intended the glowing nintendo sores
won't help you now oh the gloves are
coming off I have never been able to say
that and then literally true but now it
is Wolfie means business I like that
this is like the gloves came off but
they're still gloves on multi-tiered
glove action here in ultra street
fighter 4 as Wolfie takes on Combofiend
cami starting strong against Balrog what
a difference it makes to not have furry
paws on I don't know if we get a little
crowd momentum here for Wolfie can we
get some cheering
pull one out here go on don't go quietly
into that good night all well done a
valiant effort I don't even know how
well you can see out of those eyes of
yours but uh well done Wolfie up Valley
into play we'll get someone else up here
to play on street fighter for whatsapp
of hand for our competitor here this hat
real quick that thing is wow I can't
even it's nice good luck